in one very dramatic scene documented in
1901 scientists observing the species
aolosoma tenobrarum described the way
these chains of worms would twist up in
each other creating a writhing Tangled
ball of worms that would stay stuck
together for long periods of time and
when the scientists pulled these balls
apart they usually found at least one
worm that had been partially eaten but
when your Ayla Soma it's not that big of
a deal honestly it's not much more than
an inconvenience because if a part of it
gets eaten it can always regenerate in
one case the scientists watching these
balls of worms found that one worm had
its head eaten but in about three days
it was able to make a new one it would
probably have taken less time to
regenerate other parts of their body
heads seemed to take the yellow Soma a
bit longer perhaps because of all the
complex parts that need to be rebuilt
and the alesoma can regenerate even when
it is cut into multiple segments